hey 42 here the current Ebola virus
outbreak in West Africa is the largest
and most widespread in history with over
21,000 known cases to date and Counting
let's reveal some surprising facts about
this deadly virus the first known
instance of Ebola was in 1976 it
appeared in czar in the Democratic
Republic of the Congo and killed 280
people but the 1976 case may not have
been the first outbreak a study on
infectious diseases suggested that the
first outbreak of Ebola may have
occurred around 430 BC in ancient Greece
the writings of foo cities described a
virulent disease that wiped out half of
the city of Athens his description of
the disease's symptoms is very similar
to Ebola including uncontrollable
bleeding Ebola is named after the Ebola
River in the Democratic Republic of the
Congo which is 60 miles away from the
first ever case of the virus during the
current Ebola outbreak a handful of West
African countries have been infected and
nine non African countries Spain Germany
France Switzerland the Netherlands
Norway Italy the UK and the USA past
Ebola outbreaks have had fertility rates
of up to 90 percent but the fertility
rate of the current outbreak in West
Africa is 50 percent however outside of
Africa the fertility rate is much lower
the current fertility rate in the United
States and Europe is a significantly
lower 20 percent proving that where
you're treated makes an enormous
difference
Ebola is not airborne and therefore
cannot in its current form be
transmitted through the air via coughing
Oh
easing it also can't be transmitted
through water or food the virus can only
be transmitted through direct contact of
the blood or bodily fluids of an Ebola
sufferer
this makes Ebola surprisingly difficult
to spread when compared to more
contagious diseases such as measles or
influenza because of this many disease
specialists have said that Ebola poses
no threat to wealthier countries in
Europe and North America because of
their higher hygiene standards and
better disease containment capabilities
2014 is not the first time in history
that Ebola has appeared in the United
States in 1989 macaque monkeys in the
primate unit of the Hazelton research
products lab in Reston Virginia began
dying with Ebola like symptoms four
workers were exposed to the virus and
the military and CDC were called in to
eliminate the monkeys and qualen teen
the humans but strangely it appeared to
be a new strain of Ebola that was only
lethal to primates the new strain did
however display a frightening new
ability to go airborne for the first
time there is currently no
tried-and-tested vaccine for Ebola but
in September 2014 a clinical trial of a
potential new Ebola vaccine was able to
protect monkeys against the virus in a
hundred percent of cases the same
vaccine has just begun a trial at Oxford
University on humans for the first time
ever if the trials are successful the
company that manufactures the vaccine
says it could have two million doses of
the vaccine available this year several
potential cures for the Ebola virus are
also currently being developed and
tested one of the most promising is
called zmapp
it was given to seven Ebola patients two
of whom
Gide showing a reasonable success rate
but the drug is difficult and
time-consuming to make and the limited
supply has now been exhausted it will
take several months to manufacture a new
batch however seven other potential
Ebola cures are currently undergoing
clinical trials there are five known
strains of the Ebola virus these strains
are called Tsar Sudan Tay forests Reston
and Bundy bugia named after the
locations of each strains patient zero
a person who survives an Ebola infection
is then immune to that particular strain
but is still susceptible to the other
four strains one of the biggest
challenges facing the containment of the
Ebola outbreak is misinformation and
distrust of health professionals in West
Africa many sufferers of Ebola
don't seek medical care as they fear
going into isolation and being around
other Ebola patients this vastly
increases the chance of the individual
transmitting the virus to friends and
family there is also a tradition in West
Africa of washing dead bodies before
burial this has vastly increased the
rate of infection and is a significant
issue in the current outbreak because
Ebola can live on a patient's skin for
several days after death meaning you
could get infected from simply touching
the corpse of an Ebola victim then
touching your mouth or eyes it is still
not known where Ebola actually comes
from but evidence suggests that fruit
bats are the natural carriers of the
disease research suggests that the
patient zero of the current outbreak was
a two-year-old in Guinea who had
recently been playing in a battery when
he contracted the disease known as
bushmeat bats and other wild animals are
frequently eaten by natives of Guinea
and bats soup is a delicacy in the
region which could also
have contributed to the start of the
current Ebola outbreak thanks for the
view subscribe for more thoughty2
you